öffnet man gerade den trends kopieren
damit man ein paar klicks bekommt katy
rebell übel zugerichtet wirkt mich
eigentlich eher nicht so episode 3 habe
ich nicht gestellt von mcdonald's
deutschland ab 14 uhr in die trends
gekauft worden
sexualkunde schult von stuhr waffe
ich frag mal freddy ob er das in ordnung
findet wenn ich auch so schult mal
machen koch.de wie funktioniert die
scheiße jetzt sie können hier oben auf
auswahl klicken und sehen schon
grundschule dann kriegen wir das erste
klappe machen einen mathematikaufgaben
und hängt direkt an den obersten zehn
frösche gesondert laut quakte
nachtfröste wie viele flächen leise wir
denken jetzt einfach mal die lösung auf
drückt ihr den bernern den kopf neben
einem bau stehen 243 hier schon zwei
vögel wie viele beine haben sie zu
weniger als wenn das erste klasse ist
also eine re hat sehen bei einhalten
zweimal clean beide sind 20 ein hirsch
hat quelle beine kaum schrecken der hier
schön also bisher 20 beine
dann haben wir noch zwei vögel ein vogel
hat heinlein also 20 club 101 77 beine
ich klicke einfach auflösung aufdecken
und in einer schulklasse sind 20 kinder
entfielen davon sind buben wie viele
mädchen sind es jetzt echt eine relativ
simple frage also wir haben quasi 20
kinder in der schulklasse und sehen da
von den buben also endlich das heißt wir
haben null mädchen das mädchen sind doof
dass jeder ein bube will zusammen mit
einem mädchen
sehen
das muss
ein system sein die geldbeträge richtig
zu jetzt nämlich eine handtasche ein
gerät in der handtasche befindet sich
einen fünf euro schein ein euro stück
jeder dumme menschen denken fünf euro
schein ein euro stück ist doch logisch
sind sechs euro aber nein freunde die
hand lasse kostet auch noch geld du mich
dass wir erkennen dass mit gepäck kostet
zwei euro
wir rechnen jetzt die sechs euro plus
die zwei euro kommen dementsprechend 62
euro okay sagt bautista wald bei euro
plus 2 euro plus zwei euro sind sechs
euro denkt der normale mensch das
allerdings keine gute bloomberg die
kostet nämlich schon zwei euro also 682
verrechnet also 8 die wollen mich
verarschen in der dose sind 20
büroklammern zuerst verbraucht die
lehrerin drei klammern und später noch
weg klammern wie viele klammern wird
noch in der dose wieder eine fangfrage
und waren wir 20 büroklammern in der
dose und lehrerin verbraucht er drei
knabbert und dann nochmal sechs klammern
allerdings ist eine lehrerin ja nicht
dumm
die nimmt der klammer nicht auf einer
stufe lehrerinnen sind kluge menschen
und die nehmen die klammern dort wo die
herkommen
also vom klammer baum derzeit mit der
note sind immer noch 20 klammern also
ich weiß nicht warum die fina hat in
ihrer spardose 27 euro sie kaufte sich
ein meerschweinchen für acht euro wie
viel geld hat die noch übrig gar nicht
weil sie noch futter kaufen muss neben
dem futter muss noch ein spiel her es
muss auch eine stahltür her muss noch
ein wassernapf er es wird noch heuer
soll ich sagen sie hat - 400 euro jetzt
in der tasche deswegen denken 19 euro
bieten
[Musik]
meine damen und herren ich habe mir
einfach mal gedacht die marten schulte
sorting bestehen würde
nein würde ich nicht wenn es euch
gefallen hat er vor gerne live videos in
der beschreibung und verlinkt und jetzt
rollt das auto rein
video ihr könnt jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen
strecken ihr plädiert für andere video
nun endlich wenn die auch die glocke
klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]